So the objectives of this lesson are for
you to learn about
what is Dynamic Range.
We will specifically talk about Dynamic
Range as a concept that applies to
images, and how we want to be able to
capture real scenes with the lighting
and radiometric information of the scene
to capture the best possible image.
We'll also think about what makes or
prevents a camera to be able to
capture dynamic range correctly.
Specifically talking about
digital cameras, and
how they encode information?
Or do not encode the information
of dynamic range of an image.
We will talk about
the Image Acquisition Pipeline.
Which is aimed at capturing the scene
brightness, the scene radiance, and
basically covert them to pixel values.
And of course,
those are the pixel values.
We can do various types of mathematics
on to generate newer types of images.
We will look at the variety
of a linear and
non-linear aspects that are inherent
in an image acquisition pipeline.
That will allow us to
start thinking what,
what kind of mapping we want
to model and build upon.
In this lesson, we will also cover
aspects of camera calibration.
That will allow us to
calibrate a camera, so
we can actually be able to get
the right kinds of levels of images and
colors, that are actually visible
in the scene, into a real image.
So the goal here is to
calibrate a camera,
so we will be able to look at
the exact colors in a scene, and
be able to capture all of those
to replicate them in an image.
We will then discuss
how we can take values,
the pixel values of intensities from
different exposures of an image.
Again, this is where a camera comes in,
how we'll use the exposure?
You know,
to remember things like aperture and
shutter, to then actually capture
the light information, and
then use that to generate
a new image of the scene.
And then we'll talk about Tone Mapping.
Which is aimed at taking a high dynamic
range image and then converting it in
a form that would be made visible
on the traditional display or
perhaps even bring it out so
you can actually see all the different
types of dynamic range in that image.